la gran popularidad de la reina isabel
segunda hizo que su jubileo de platino
en junio se celebrará a lo grande en
reino unido- y en todo el mundo pero
ahora tras su muerte los historiadores y
expertos se repiten una pregunta cuál es
el futuro de la corona británica de la
monarquía y la reina son sinónimos para
la mayoría pero creo que al dejar atrás
su reinado todas las apuestas sobre la
posición que la opinión pública va a
tomar respecto a carlos son malas porque
es alguien que puede ser criticado y
desafiado desde el escándalo tras las
denuncias de abusos sexuales contra el
príncipe andrew que lo obligaron a
renunciar a sus títulos reales en 2002
hasta las acusaciones de racismo por
parte de harry nieto de la reina y su
esposa megan la familia real ha estado
envuelta en varias polémicas algo que se
suma a la escasa popularidad de carlos
tercero respecto a su madre las
encuestas entre los menores de 30 años
han cambiado drásticamente en los dos
últimos años y ahora la mayoría quiere
deshacerse de la monarquía no obstante
en los últimos sondeos previos al
jubileo de platino la reina mostraron
que un 83 de los británicos seguía
apoyando la monarquía con isabel 2a
el sistema democrático es duro casi
brutal pero al menos el mensaje es claro
para todos sin embargo para nosotros la
familia real el mensaje es a menudo más
difícil de leer oscurecido por la
retórica o la opinión pública
responsabilidad e incerteza que ahora
recaen sobre su hijo carlos tercero y
sus respectivos sucesores